[Music]
you
and hey I'm Erskine I'm the CTO outside
the state and I'm excited to be here
today I'm going to talk about what you
learned over the years in turning
Postgres into a distributed database and
some of these lessons are also
applicable in a broader context than
just podcasts or relational databases I
have about 45 slides and this is a
fairly technical talk so if you have
questions please ask them and before I
start I also have a quick question for
you how many of you are familiar with or
have worked with Postgres actually
awesome awesome
almost everyone and now before we start
I'll share with you just five slides to
introduce the context behind my talk
what is situs why am I here presenting
this talk and what can you expect to get
out of this talk the answer to all these
questions is our rock-solid relational
database Postgres this diagram here
shows job posting trends over time on
Hacker News and as of last year
Postgres is as popular as the next four
databases combined on these job postings
and it's worth learning more about the
technical components that make up
Postgres and how long goes about scaling
them so a slide one developers love
Postgres I must go in the city out situs
data previously I worked on distributed
systems at amazon.com and I love
Postgres to our team also loves post
quest and our situs data we focus on
scaling out Postgres and to assess point
making sharding simple so you can focus
on your application and not worry about
your database at situs data every single
engineer on the team shares the same
mission to make it so that you never
have to worry about scaling your
database again and if your own ireland
familiar with situs if this is the first
time you're viewing it there are just a
few things to know before we dive into
the challenges of distributing Postgres
one situs is a distributed database that
horizontally scales
Postgres across multiple machines using
Chardonnay and replication behind the
covers cytosis query engine routes and
paralyzes sequel queries across the
machines in the cluster to repackage
Saito's as an extension these extension
api's are new and unique to Postgres and
more on them later in this talk and
situs is available in three ways first
as open source second as a fully managed
database service on AWS and third as
enterprise software and finally here's a
simplified architectural diagram of
situs we have a coordinator node here
and worker nodes here these are regular
post critical databases that have the
situs accession loaded the user or the
application connects to and interacts
with the coordinator node this is where
you create your table and I'll say
distribute table when you run a query
against this coordinator node basically
you use this at your standard post case
equal library or your tools and then the
coordinator transforms that particular
query into smaller queries pushes down
to the worker node gets the results back
merges them and gives Done back to your
application so very simple there is no
data usually not much data captured on
the coordinator node so it only
coordinates work and each worker node in
here captures the actual data as small
shard at tables
so one shard is equal to one table one
post base table but all of this is
invisible to you so that previous
diagram looks pretty simple but scaling
a sequel is actually an extremely
challenging task and then this tall
presentation talks about three different
challenges that relate to scaling
process since these are related about
different topics
one way to think of this presentation is
as three separate shorter talks this way
if you're super bored during the talk
you just have to wait it out for another
five minutes or so
and then we'll be talking about
something completely different in my
first talk I'm going to describe
replication and high-availability
techniques in Postgres in my second talk
let's say you decided to build a
distributed relational database do you
build from scratch or one from scratch
or do you fork an existing database then
I'll dive into one of the baddest
meanest problems with scaling relational
databases distributed transactions and
I'm going to conclude a talk with that
let's switch gears start first two
lightning talk this talk describes the
most asked question about podcasts how
do you handle replication and machine
failures what challenges do you run into
we are setting up highly available
process clusters the typical approach to
replication in relational databases is
the following you have one primary node
all your rights go to the primary node
and the primary node applies the changes
there and then it takes those changes
and and pushes down or the secondary
nodes pull them to the secondary nodes
one or more secondary nodes and in the
context of Postgres this setup brings
two challenges for applications for
clients first many post grants clients
are set up are implemented to talk to a
single end point so in this setup when
your primary node fails most prosperous
clients will keep retrying that end
point that IP or that host name second
post case replicates its entire state so
when you are replicating that much state
it becomes hard to shoot like shoot
different nodes in the head or bring up
new nodes in the cluster into the
cluster going back to the first problem
to reiterate on that first problem the
issue here is that process has a massive
ecosystem of clients as some of these
clients are smarter for example the Java
client the JDBC client can see a failure
and we try a different endpoint
however when we're solving this problem
for the masses for everyone
you need to rely on networking
primitives so this networking primitive
could be an elastic IP or DNS or a load
balancer or this could be services in
communities deployments and here in this
example we have Europe we have our
application in here this could be Ruby
this could be Python and then it's
talking to this end point which is an
elastic IP when the primary node fails
the monitoring agent in here promotes
the secondary detaches the elastic IP
from the primary we attaches it to the
secondary so this way this application
doesn't need to change the endpoint it's
talking tor you don't need to implement
application level logic everything just
happens magically for your Postgres
client
the second problem isn't as widely
recognized as a problem so most people
and I used to think this too that when
you have this simple primary secondary
architecture there is one way to solve a
problem right because there is only a
primary and there are multiple secondes
but in practice if you look at post
grace deployments out there on on pram
on RDS on Heroku they end up following
one of three approaches for replication
and failover and there is an easy way to
identify the approach they're following
let's say you add a brand new secondary
node into your clusters how do you
reconstruct that secondary nodes State
so the first approach is the most common
and the most typical one you have one
primary node and this primary node has
the tables data in here and the right
head logs out of curiosity how many
people in here have heard of a right
head logs or wild logs in Postgres ok
about about a third so this world log
right head log is basically you have
process when you modify a row in process
the change first gets committed to an
append-only
redo log so that if Postgres were to
crash we can replay the changes from the
log and then in this example this
actually captures all the changes to
your database and the wall
get streamed over to a secondary node
and on the secondary not actually
replays the changes from the right
headwalls
and in this first approach when you
build a new secondary node let's say you
brought up a very new secondary node
this secondary node needs to replay the
entire state
the primary captures from the beginning
of time and now so it can reconstruct
that state and of course when you're
bringing a new secondary know this
operation introduces a significant load
on your primary and this one becomes
even more important if your primary is
under heavy load which is when you want
to bring up these secondary nodes and
also in this first approach in the
simple approach you can use local disks
or attach persistent volumes during
sisters in this diagram I'm using local
disks because that's the more typical
setup the second approach relies on disk
mirroring or you can think of it as file
system replication in this approach
where your changes get synchronously
written to a persistent volume and then
this volume per synchronously gets
mirrored to another volume and the nice
thing about this file system replication
approaches that it works for all
relational databases you can use it for
my sequel Pasqua sequel Oracle or sequel
server however this approach requires
that you replicate both your table data
and write head log data and further each
write that you do here on the primary
gets replicated synchronously over the
network so you can't even miss a single
byte here because file system doesn't
know about the underlying data if you
were to missile a few bytes your
database would go in a corrupt state and
the third approach turns the replication
and disaster recovery process inside out
so you write you write to the primary
node the primary node does a full backup
every day and incremental backups every
60 seconds to here this cloud in here
and your secondary usually follows the
primary node except that when you
introduce a new secondary Norden here it
reconstructs
entire state from s3 or from the blob
storage engine here so this way you
don't introduce any additional load on
the primary database you can bring up a
new secondary and reconstruct it
entirely from s3 and when the secondary
is close enough to the primary you can
start start streaming from the primary
and catch up with it
so this design itself lends itself more
to our cloud-based architecture because
you can bring up or shoot down secondary
nodes at will and you can also use
synchronous or asynchronous replication
because you're capturing the changes in
these up and only logs I'll take a quick
pause here any questions about the
previous three slides or the three
approaches I'll take a quick poll does
it make sense to these like three
approaches generally make sense okay
cool and here's a simple table that
compares these approaches to each other
and for each approach you can think of
its benefits column as the drawbacks of
the other approaches simple streaming
replication is the most common approach
most on priam deployments fall of this
approach it's trivial it's easy to set
up further if you are using local discs
you can store tons of terabytes of data
comparatively the disk mirroring
approach abstracts away the storage
layer from the database in this approach
when you lose an instance you don't lose
your fo million disk with it this
approach works with my sequel post case
Oracle which is great if you're a cloud
vendors such as AWS and in the third
method when you add a new machine if you
reconstruct that machine straight from
right head launch since you're treating
your right head logs as a first class
citizen certain features become trivial
for example let's say you wanted to
performance test your application
against your production data but not
against your production database in the
third approach you can easily take a
fork of your cluster because these are
all logs living in s3 and then you can
run your application against a
production data and I shut it down that
will
sort of oops interesting let me escape
and try this again
awesome we're back so in summary post
best comes with 3d application methods
if you rely on the storage layer or s3
when reconstructing a secondary node you
can easily bring up or shut down
databases so that's the cloud native
part of it this is because your
secondary reconstruction isn't
introducing load on your primary
database and it's worth noting that all
three replication methods that I
described replicate our databases state
info and this is also one of the
benefits of sharding when you share your
database the state you need to replicate
per machine becomes smaller so
reapplication becomes a much easier
problem to solve with this I'll conclude
our first talk and this brings us to our
second talk let's say we decided to
shard our relational database and when
you think of shutting a relational
database you are talking about taking
diverse features built over in Hospice
in the case of hospice 20 years of
making all of those features distributed
so how do you go about this at a high
level there were three ways to build a
distributed database one build a
distributed database from scratch to you
take a widely used relational database
you put a middleware layer in front of
it this middleware layer usually wraps
queries such as simple in stores or
lookup queries to the underlying sharded
database and three you fork an open
source database and make it distributed
and the fourth database supports the
original databases features as of the
time of the fork and usually diverges
over time and it essence becomes a
separate project so which one of these
approaches would you pick where are we
started working on site as we said okay
let's ask around and see what type of
queries people send to their databases
so my co-founder rumors started
forwarding example queries and email
threads
and then this is very early we're just
getting into the world or Postgres and
one day you must force me this query
black and I'm reading through this thing
and then okay there is a transaction
here there is a sequence here there is a
join here there is a returning here and
then there is this thing called save
points I open up the post quest manual
and it turns out Postgres also supports
nested transactions so you can create a
bookmark in your transaction and roll
back to a particular bookmark within
that transaction if you'd like to I'm
like thinking man where dozen will find
these queries and this was a week or so
after like he went to Burning Man so I'm
thinking if he's imagined this thing or
something cuz if you look at the query
the query doesn't even make any sense
like at the end of the query the entire
transaction is rolled back so we debate
a little if we should even support this
type of nested transaction blocks and
I'm like I'm fine
I'd like to meet the jr. genius who
wrote this transaction block anyway
let's go and meet them so you're gonna
meet this company and it turns out there
was no genius at this company who wrote
this transaction block this was a rails
testing framework that auto-generated
this query and at that point one thing
became quite apparent if he wanted to
scale out Postgres we had to go all in
for a post press user all of the futures
they rely on need to linearly scale this
includes current and new features
clients or Rams and hundreds of tools
built around Postgres so you had to head
down for Postgres with style what does
it mean to fork with style if you look
at post pass and and this is a
architecture diagram from post guess
nine dot or it has a fairly modular and
extensible architecture in here you can
look into any module change or extend
its behavior without making a mess and
the diagram shows the different modules
within focus for example if you wanted
to distribute the create index command
so you can't push it in parallel across
all your charts you hook into this DDL
and utility processing module and the
most calm
complex boxes in this diagram are the
query planner and executor don't before
that they look like these nice little
boxes they're actually fairly complex
and then they were at the time highly
coupled and they made assumptions
actually about these little boxes
underneath which are which represent in
storage layer so we decide okay this is
the hardest part and we created a
two-stage query planner and executor
what what does that mean that means once
Postgres parses and semantically
validates to query sytrus checks if the
query touches distributed tables if it
does Saito's uses distributed table
metadata to plan the query for
distributed query execution during the
planning step Saito's plans to minimize
network i/o and transforms the query
into smaller query fragments Saito's
done the parses these query fragments
back into sequel and that sends them to
workers as sequel why convert query
fragments back to sequel two reasons
first this way we can decouple the
distributed query planner from the
distributed query executors and test the
planner and executors separately so if
you're writing regression tests you can
enable logging and check that the
generated queries that we stand between
the coordinator and workers are what we
expect them to be a second once we
create these smaller sequel query
fragments I ship them to worker launch
Postgres there can apply its own query
optimization and optimize that query for
local execution so I'll make this
concrete he is a simple example the
application here issue is a select query
to the coordinator and the coordinator
parses the query this is post guess at
that point siteís kicks in transforms
the parse query into query fragments
which in this example are different so
we're taking the query and and
transforming it into it's committed to
form and then we take that query
fragments those query fragments departs
turn back into sequel Sandown to worker
nodes the worker nodes do their own
planning sound the results back to the
coordinator the coordinator does the
final computation and gives them back to
the application
and we were quite happy with Harvey for
Postgres what made things even better
was that post quest I made these api's
official with an extension framework so
we unform Postgres made site as an
official extension how many of you have
heard of post case equals extension
api's okay about a fifth or a sixth so
in post case an extension is a shared
library that gets dynamically loaded
into post cases address space and then
this way the user can start a podcast
and just type rate extension sytrus and
voila in the case of Saito's your
favorite relational database becomes a
distributed database before I conclude
that see if this is going to work well
okay
this is a bit cut off but then this is I
wanted to show you the initialization
logic how you hook into post cases
extension modules this is from sytrus
the github project we were basically
initializing some ourselves in the
dynamic memory segment so they're a
bunch of checks in here once we did that
we say okay we need a few extra
directories so we tell post case I
create these directories for us we
registered our configuration variables
with the post-classical config subsystem
we intercept the planner
we do intercept the executor at a
different place but Danny basically we
intercept that utility hope this is the
DDL logic so we basically say hey hook
me in into the DDL logic we do a bunch
of other planner folks we hook the log
like logging engine so that when you
arrive we can also clean up our
resources we initialize background
worker processes so this is these are
things that we spawn along with Postgres
and then that does background work we
initialize the transaction sub engine
like we hook into the transaction and
the connection management module and
then we do one final check and we we
have done the initialization and
obviously all of these function calls
are fairly involved and they hook into a
Postgres equals internals
awesome we're back
any questions up to this point all right
with that I'll conclude our second talk
on using Postgres equals extension api's
and they slide into our third talk
handling distributed transactions in a
relational database so distributed
transactions is one of the meanest
baddest problems in databases you do a
begin transaction in certain an update
and once you do not select you should
see your changes applied against the
database but others shouldn't until you
do a commit or you do a rollback and
your changes should disappear forever
and there are two challenges associated
with running distributed transactions
these challenges are like two sides of a
coin the first challenge is how do you
handle consistency in distributed
databases what happens when you're doing
a transaction and one or multiple
machines that participate in that
transaction failed consistency is a
well-established problem in distributed
systems three popular algorithms in the
space include two PC Paxos and raft and
the variants of these algorithms and the
primary difference between two PC there
and Paxos from a practical standpoint is
- PC needs all participating nodes to be
available to progress whereas in Paxos
you can get away with a quorum and in
sytrus we looked both into a PC that's
built into podcasts actually post PS
comes with two PC and then we also
deployed an experimental expansion
called PG Paxos and we decided to go
with two PC because it has been widely
used in production across post basical
deployments and also cyclists use the
streaming replication if you remember
the first talk so when a node becomes
unavailable its secondary usually gets
promoted within a minute so since the
consistency challenge is widely accepted
and discussed I won't dive deeper into
it in this talk instead I'll talk about
Lester recognized but just as important
problem for relational databases let's
say you have a complex transaction block
that modifies multiple rows which is in
here and actually I have four of them
what happens when you have done
concurrently running concurrently and
then they modify the same roles in
distributed tables but in different
orders it turns out that one of the
trickiest things we need to deal with is
a very simple thing it's really
important to databases namely locks
Allah protects concurrent access to the
same data in other words a lock prevents
two transactions from modifying the same
row at the same time but in databases
transactions can be quite complicated
they can grab many different locks and
at some point they could end up waiting
on each other that's known as a deadlock
this is a very bad situation that needs
to be dealt with otherwise you cannot
reliably run your database so let's zoom
in a bit on where and when we run into
locks in post-classical well there is
many different cases but pretty much any
command that you run we have some locks
what an important example is the raw
level lock if you update a row in
process that update in here grabs a lock
and any concurrent transaction that
tries to update destroy em row will then
block until the first transaction is
finished which means either when the
first transaction commits or abort and
then after the commit or abort all locks
are released and the second transaction
can continue now if two transactions
don't modify the same row because their
filters aren't conflicting they can run
concurrently and this is a very nice
thing about Postgres because it brings
great write throughput but maybe you
have this transaction are later in the
transaction in here you do something
that conflicts with an ongoing
transaction so that you still block
and now while you're blocking the second
transaction on the right the first
transaction is also holding on to the
locks that are acquired in its first
statement ok but what happens if the
first transaction then also tries to
modify a transaction from the other like
a row from the other transaction so they
both modified the same rows but in a
different order the transaction on the
right hold owns calls on two locks on
the rows where x equals to 2 and the
transaction on the Left holds onto locks
on rows where x equals to 1 and now they
rating on each other there is no way out
of the situation there is no way to get
both of these transactions to commit
because neither of them can continue
this is a deadlock and the reason
deadlocks are particularly bad is
because not only do these two
transactions get stuck any new
transaction that comes in and tries to
acquire one of these locks that the
previous transaction souls will also
block and maybe that block transaction
will then block other transactions so a
deadlock can actually escalate into a
full system outage if left unchecked
where all processes are blocked
of course both glass has to solve this
problem now the way Postgres deals with
this is if a transaction is stuck
waiting for a lock for more than a
second it runs a deadlock detection code
and the deadlock detection gathers the
lock graph across all processes the lock
tables across all processes and then
builds a graph where each mode is a
transaction so this is a transaction
this is a transaction and the edge in
this graph says this transaction is
waiting for this other transaction and
then if there is a cycle in this graph
Postgres knows that there is a deadlock
when Postgres detects a deadlock it
cancels some of the transactions until
that cycle does gun in this case
Postgres might cancel one of the
transactions performing the update and
then that ends the transaction and then
that means the counsel transaction locks
are released then other transactions
which are blocked waiting can now
continue finish so one transaction dies
another
in situs we also support transactions
you can the begin update update but site
Estella gates transactions to the law
that actually stores your distributed
tables charts so here for example on the
coordinator node if you do two
transaction blocks with updates in
opposite orders they get delegated to
node 1 then if it was a transaction
skater deadlock post case will not one
will say hmm there is a cycle in the
slack graph I'm going to cancel one of
the transactions that sends back an
error message to the coordinator the
coordinator will then abort the whole
transaction the other transactions that
were blocked waiting can't continue
running so okay that works what what if
the transaction what if this transaction
spans across multiple nodes in this
example one of my roles in the second
new example is on node one and there is
another role on node 3 transaction d1 is
now waiting for the two on node 1 and d2
is waiting for node for d1 1 or 3 the
coordinator is just waiting to get a
response for queries that is sent to
these two nodes and the Postgres will no
three doesn't see a deadlock the post
case all node one doesn't have a
deadlock the coordinator doesn't have a
deadlock but if you look at the whole
picture there is a deadlock so this is
the situation we have to deal with in
order to safely support distributed
transactions and what we did inside of
seven is add a new component to sytrus
which is the distributed deadlock
detector this component runs as a
background worker as part of the
extension framework so this was the
background workers that we started
earlier on in our second talk and if a
distributed transaction gets stuck it
gathers all the log tables from all the
nodes and then starts building a
distributed transaction graph and I saw
the distributed deadlock detector here
in this box
associates the transactions that go on
node 1 and node 3 with the distributed
transactions on the coordinator and then
the deadlock detector can say oh this
distributed transaction is waiting for
this other distributed transaction will
no three
then you can perform deadlock detection
on the graph and it will see the cycle
the deadlock detector can then cancel
the transaction on the coordinator which
will abort the transactions on node 1
and node 3 as well and this way other
distributed transactions can continue so
this is necessary for implementing
distributed transactions on a shard the
database safely in summary distributed
transactions are a complex topic most
articles on this topic focus on the more
visible problem around data consistency
these articles done discussed protocols
such as to PC Paxos or raft in practice
data consistency is only one side of the
coin on the other side of this coin is
distributed deadlocks and when your
application runs concurrent transaction
blocks that modify rows in different
orders you may run into a deadlock if
you want to scale out your relational
database distributed deadlock detection
or avoidance is just as important as
data consistency with that I'll wrap our
third talk and on to the conclusion we
talked about three technical problems
today first replication and high
availability in post-classical
second process equals extraction api's
and how Saito's leverage is done to
introduce distributed database
functionality and last distributed
deadlock detection and the unifying
theme across all of them was scaling out
the relational database I actually
started out as a developer building a
Gascon sequel databases and there are
actually good things to be said about
most sequel databases I can see our VP
of Marketing getting stumped right here
in the front row we're like wait did he
just say there are good things about
logical databases or what is he doing
like oh and the thing is going back to
the talk when we start the situs the
database of choice among developers was
no sequel so when we said host guess
we'd often be dismissed as sequel
doesn't scale
and the thing is it's really easy to
dismiss a seemingly intractable problem
by making a statement that trivializes
the problem and the best way to solve a
complex problem is not by dismissing the
problem but by breaking it up into
smaller problems and solving them one by
one and we found that Saito start
scaling out sequel isn't one about eight
different problems in this talk I talked
about three of those challenges and how
we approach to solving them I hope you
enjoyed learning about these three
challenges but if you'd still like me to
simplify my conclusion to one not three
takeaways I say this I learned this one
thing through sweat joy and tears in the
past five years scaling out sequel is a
very very very hard but not an
impossible problem to solve thank you
questions we do have office hours after
this one and I'd be happy to chat about
the three challenges in more detail or
the five other challenges that I haven't
discussed after I don't know how much
time we have I think about one or two
more minutes so if you have any
questions like I'm happy to answer them
here or during office hours how do you
deal with the deal with reliability with
the coordinator nodes I go to the
coordinator know he was down so in the
previous slide on this was a simplified
diagram give me one sec I'll walk over
it by in the default and simplified set
up the coordinator node also has a
replica like also has a steaming
reapplication replica so if it fails
then the replica for the coordinator
mode gets promoted we do also have one
advanced version of Cyprus which most
users don't need but it's still
available where that distributed
metadata can be replicated to all the
nodes that way any node can become a
coordinator node you say you're looking
for a solution for ski ops Postgres
right and we actually went to a Douglas
conference earlier and they announced
they have the aurora for Postgres which
can also scale up so can you summarize
say what's the difference between your
solution versus the AWS Aurora and okay
what's your training what's your kind of
advantage over their solution so I'll
give two answers to that question
because I think it's a two-fold answer
one is obviously sytrus is open source
and it's available anywhere so you're
not locked in today ws infrastructure
you carry on it anyway good lawyer you
choose the second answer is more
technical what all it does is it takes
two storage layers and it scales the
storage layer so in here if you look at
this picture now go back the volume the
persistent volume that you had
effectively becomes our a bigger volume
that has better latency and that enables
you to scale the storage so you can
store more data and what cytus does is
to go fully distributed
like in this picture where you can talk
to any one of the nodes you scale not
only storage but memory and CPU you can
not only read but write to any one of
the nodes in the cluster like in the MS
Office so that's the primary difference
Aurora approaches it more at the storage
layer and now situs approaches it more
at the data base there I read the post
uses the same means so a table is
database normally there are a few
version behind the open-source version
so how about your solution so Aurora is
in those terms is a fork of podcasts
where they actually fall from the core
project undone they rebasing with situs
going into this extension method because
it's an extension to post by sequel
it basically anything that's enforce
case equal whenever it comes out is
available to you at the time that it
comes out and any functionality enforce
case by virtuous having leverage these
api's becomes available to the users
without becoming a fork immediately does
that answer your question
like say the hll extension for posters
oh yeah
how does situs work with other postgrads
extensions so for example like the hyper
log-log Postgres extension or time or
time scale for the hyperbola extension I
can answer the question and the default
answer is 95 to 99 percent of the time
it just works nicely because the way we
hooked into the API is as we paid
attention like what we need to work in
hyper long long extension is actually
used by quite a few Saito's customers
where they use the hyper log log or now
there is a top an extension to represent
like approximate count distance so you
say create extension situs you say
create extension hyper load log on all
the machines and then they just happen
to work together because we paid
attention how we should hook into these
api's as we were designing them
[Music]